>>> MINUTES FROM NOW THE LAUNCH
WINDOW WILL OPEN FOR THE SPACEX
FALCON HEAVY ROCKET.
THIS MARKS THE FIRST TIME THE
ROCKET HAS BEEN LAUNCHED IN
THREE YEARS.
IT'S ON A MISSION FOR U.S. SPACE
FORCE.
CNN'S MARTIN SAVAGE IS FOLLOWING
THIS.
WHAT MORE DO WE KNOW ABOUT THE
LAUNCH AND THE COLLABORATION
BETWEEN SPACEX AND SPACE FORCE?
>> LOOK AT THE IMAGERY THERE.
STARK AND SHROUDED IN FOG.
WEATHER CAN IMPACT A LAUNCH, BUT
FOG IS NOT NECESSARILY ONE OF
THEM.
LOOK AT THE COUNTDOWN THERE AS
IT IS PROGRESSING.
THE SPACEX HEAVY IS INTERESTING
BECAUSE WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
THIS PARTICULAR MISSION IS IT'S
THE USSF, UNITED STATES SPACE
FORCE, MISSION 44 AND THE FOG IS
NOT THE ONLY THING SHROUDING
THIS LAUNCH.
IT'S SHROUDED IN MYSTERY
SOMEWHAT.
IT'S CONSIDERED A SECRET
MISSION.
THERE ARE TWO MAJOR PAYLOADS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE LAUNCHED.
IN MOST OF THESE LAUNCHES YOU
GET TO WATCH EVERYTHING.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO BE THE CASE
ONCE IT GETS TO THE SECOND STAGE
OF THIS MISSION BECAUSE
SOMETIMES, WHEN YOU RELEASE
INFORMATION SUCH AS WHEN DO THE
ENGINES STOP, THAT CAN GIVE YOU
AN INDICATION OF WHERE THIS
PAYLOAD IS GOING TO BE IN ORBIT
AND THE GOVERNMENT DOESN'T WANT
YOU TO KNOW THAT AT THIS
PARTICULAR TIME BECAUSE THIS IS
PART OF A NATIONAL SECURITY
MISSION.
INTERESTING THAT YOU CAN'T
CLEARLY SEE THIS MISSION TOO
WELL ON TELEVISION WHEN, IN
FACT, IT'S NOT GOING TO BE SEEN
WELL IN THE SPY WORLD AS WELL.
>> THE FOG IS FITTING THEN.
LET'S LISTEN IN.
WE'RE JUST ABOUT TEN SECONDS NOW
AWAY.
>> EIGHT, SEVEN, SIX, FIVE,
FOUR, THREE, TWO, ONE, ZERO --
LIFT-OFF
.
>> MARTIN SAVAGE BACK WITH US.
I WAS WORRIED ABOUT WHAT WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO SEE BECAUSE OF
THE FOG.
YOU CAN SEE A FAIR AMOUNT.
>> THAT'S PRIMARILY GROUND FOG.
IF YOU'RE ANYWHERE DOWN THERE BY
THE LAUNCH SITE, IT'S A
SPECTACULAR THING NOT JUST TO
SEE, BUT FEEL.
YOU HAVE NINE MERLIN ENGINES
CRANKING AWAY DELIVERING 5
MILLION POUNDS OF THRUST.
A LOT OF PEOPLE MAY SAY IT'S THE
MOST POWERFUL ROCKET IT IS.
NOT TRUE.
IT'S THE MOST POWERFUL ROCKET
THAT'S OPERATIONAL.
IT'S A LONG WAY OFF FROM THE OLD
SATURN 5 WHICH WAS USED TO
LAUNCH APOLLO 11 AND ALL THE
APOLLO MISSIONS.
THAT HAD ABOUT 7 MILLION POUNDS
OF THRUST AND OVER 300 FEET
TALL.
THIS IS ABOUT 260 FEET TALL.
NOT THE BIGGEST EVER, BUT STILL
QUITE AN IMPRESSIVE FEAT.
THE OTHER IMPRESSIVE THING
YOU'RE GOING TO EVENTUALLY SEE
ARE THOSE ROCKET BOOSTERS.
THERE ARE TWO OF THEM.
WE'RE ACCUSTOMED TO SEEING
THOSE.
THEY HELP DELIVER THE TRUST TO
GET YOU IN ORBIT.
THEY'LL EVENTUALLY PEEL AWAY.
THOSE TWO ARE GOING TO COME BACK
AND LAND ABOUT EIGHT MINUTES
AFTER LAUNCH.
THEY'LL LAND ABOUT NINE MILES
AWAY FROM THE LAUNCH PAD.
THAT'S ONE OF THE COOLEST THINGS
TO WATCH THESE ROCKETS RETURN,
WHICH IS PART OF THE MISSION OF
SPACEX, TO MAKE SPACE FLIGHT
MORE AFFORDABLE.
TO DO THAT, YOU MAKE IT MORE
REUSABLE, SOMETHING WITH SATURN
5 THEY DID NOT DO.
>> THAT IS KEY.
COOL TO SEE THOSE COME BACK
DOWN.
OUR FOLKS IN THE CONTROL ROOM
ARE LISTENING TO THE CONTROL
ROOM.
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT A NORMAL
TRAJECTORY, WHICH IS EXCELLENT
NEWS.
>> THERE'S THE SEPARATION.
>> WE SEE THE BOOSTER SEPARATION
THERE.
MORE CHEERING FROM THE FOLKS
BEHIND THE LAUNCH.
>> SPACEX PEOPLE LOVE THEIR
LAUNCHES.
IT'S A WHOLE NEW ERA OF SPACE
FLIGHT.
IT SHOWS YOU HOW THE GOVERNMENT
IS DEEPLY CONNECTED TO
COMMERCIAL OPERATIONS TO GET ITS
SPACE FLIGHTS BACK ON TRACK.
THIS PARTICULAR OPERATION IS RAN
BY ELON MUSK.
THERE ARE QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
MUCH A GOVERNMENT WANTS TO RELY
ON A PRIVATE CORPORATION.
THE SUCCESSES THEY'VE HAD ONE
AFTER ANOTHER SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES.
>> IT'S INTERESTING TOO.
JUST TO SEE, I WOULD SAY, THE
RENEWED INTEREST IN SPACE.
YOU TALK ABOUT WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
SEE THAT LAUNCH, TO FEEL IT.
I COVERED THE FINAL SHUTTLE
LAUNCH TEN YEARS AGO AND THAT
WALL OF SOUND THAT HITS YOU AND
THAT AMAZING MOMENTS.
THERE ARE SO QUESTIONS ABOUT
THAT.
THIS H